There is overwhelming support for FGLI
students at Yale.
Something that surprised me
is really the collaborative community.
Going to office hours, having lunch
with your professor,
learning more about their interests.
I've been surprised by how easy it is
to make connections here with professors
or even administrators.
For me, the greatest experience was
the First-Year Scholars at Yale program.
We come to New Haven for six weeks.
You take an English course
and a math course.
It's very helpful
for someone who came from a background
where we didn't have calculus
in high school.
We want students to realize
that there are a lot of students
from very similar backgrounds
to themselves here on campus.
An example of that
is actually just community dinners
that we host
at the start of each semester.
You have a mental health and counseling
services to go and just like
talk about things you overcome,
why you're proud of yourself,
what frustrates
you and it really validates your feelings.
I studied abroad in London.
It really shaped
kind of what I wanted to do in post-grad.
It was completely funded by Yale.
I'll be studying abroad in Japan
and this upcoming semester.
The only way I'm able to do it is because
Yale has wonderful financial aid.
Everybody is really here to support you
and get you through your four years here.